we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 David P here's a caller
with a very specific question take a
listen to this
hey uh David uh Sonny hey question for
you so this is made like more of a
medical expert question uh when it comes
to Navy and I I even though I am not a
medical expert I'm glad to answer as if
I were potential human hibernation the
pandemic and kind of people forceding
doors a lot a long time the winter when
it's cold
you know is it possibly like that some
sort of like
how was it like
you get what I'm saying like maybe
there's some topics or something yeah I
understand okay the idea is
we've got a pandemic and in the winter
it's flu season Etc I have coveted right
now as I talked about yesterday what if
I or we when it starts to be flu season
could hibernate could humans hibernate
skip the entire flu season first of all
if it were possible
I don't know that it actually saves us
from flu season it might just shift it
around I'm just not sure about that okay
that's number one but number two let's
talk about hibernation there is no
evidence that is very good
that humans are able to go into
hibernation which would be like an
extended state of
um uh torpor I think is the way that we
would say there's no evidence of that in
what would be called accepted Medical
Science right now the idea is widely
discussed it's been explored in science
fiction the idea of using some kind of
human hibernation uh or or reduced
metabolic state for long space travel
has been talked about these are not new
ideas but there are only speculative
commentaries that it's theoretically
possible you can find papers that say
you know ancestors to humans pre you
know pre-human ancestors
had the biological mechanics required
for hibernation and maybe with the right
technology or modifications it's
something that humans might be able to
do uh you know the the idea of cryogenic
preservation for people
um uh so that in the future if certain
diseases could be cured or whatever the
case maybe people could be reanimated
it's big topic big business but it is
quite speculative
um and uh that's sort of like where the
science is right now and much is being
researched but here's another thing
wouldn't that be very difficult socially
because even if you could
technologically and medically figure out
human hibernation
uh how how would that work socially and
culturally and psychologically it seems
like it would be a really difficult
thing I don't know that's just my sense
right now but uh an interesting question
nonetheless we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
as bad the money on the bonus show is
just crazy you should see it on today's
bonus show Joe Biden has the idea
to make South Carolina the first
Democratic primary what does South
Carolina think of it we will talk about
that on the bonus show number two
remember Michael avenatti he's been
sentenced to prison for 14 years for
fraud and it is wild wild stuff our
friend Faron cousins who was brutally
assailed by avenatti is thrilled and we
will also talk about nine million
Americans who were wrongly told that
they were approved for student loan debt
forgiveness how did it happen and what's
the story we will talk about all of it
and more on today's bonus show which you
can access by signing up right now now
you could do it later I would do it
right now at joinpakman.com